[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES MALONE: Hello, everyone.
I am James Malone.
And I'm joined here
today by Karthik,
who's going to come on
stage in a few minutes
to run through a demo.
And today we're going to talk
about Cloud Spark and Hadoop,
specifically on
Google Cloud Dataproc.
The session today is
going to mix a few things.
First, for anyone who hasn't
actually used Dataproc,
or doesn't know what
Dataproc is, or what we do,
or why we've done it, I'm
just going to set a baseline
and talk a little
bit about Dataproc,
some of the common
design patterns,
some of the common advice.
Specifically, I'm
going to try and focus
on things we told
people in the past
to try and help them go
from on-premise storing,
to other clouds,
to Cloud Dataproc.
And then I'm going
to turn it over
to Karthik, who's is
going to talk through some
of our new exciting
features, some of them
we haven't publicly
announced yet.
So you will actually be the
first group to know about some
of these.
Those features are
really designed
to help make adopting Cloud
Dataproc faster and easier.
So first I want to
start off with looking
at just traditional Spark
and Hadoop clusters.
A lot of Spark and Hadoop
clusters, when people run them,
are monolithic.
So they get a set of compute.
They get some implementation
of Spark and Hadoop.
They slap it on the
hardware they requested.
And that hardware
could be bare metal.
It could be VMs.
It could be kind of whatever.
Often we see that those
clusters are off by themselves.
There may be point integrations.
People run into the
challenges of trying
to balance that cluster,
so a configuration,
it's sort of a butterfly
flaps its wings
over here, that causes
trouble over here.
A small configuration
change, you then
have to think about how it
might impact the whole cluster.
People have tenancy
problems, either
in terms of their security
model, their resource
utilization, their
configuration.
It really ends up being a
bit of a frustrating mess
that people are just
babysitting their cluster
and paying less time
to actually getting
value out of Spark and Hadoop.
And to be honest, we see
it turns a lot of people
into really frustrated
users of Spark and Hadoop,
which is unfortunate,
because they end up
kind of hating the
tools because there's
so much just pain involved
in managing their clusters,
which sucks.
Like, it shouldn't be that way.
You should actually like the
open source you're using,
not be beholden to it.
So this is what I often
refer to as the devalue chain
of big data.
When people use open source,
you get this hardware.
You then have to configure it.
Cloud has done a good job of
removing some of this pain.
So instead of needing to rack
servers and configuring them,
you might just get a VM.
And that's great.
But even then, you have some
open source some implementation
or a proprietary implementation
of Spark and Hadoop.
You then needs to
tune it, configure it.
It is a really, really
frustrating experience
for a lot of people.
We see a lot of time
spent in people trying
to manage their clusters.
A lot of people that
we run into think
they also need to
do this because it
becomes a part of how
they've operated for so long.
So they've gotten used to
administrating their cluster.
And there's a core
set of tasks that they
think they have to do.
And when we try and peel
that away, they don't.
And a lot of time
that they could
have dedicated on writing
Spark to go look at data,
or backfilling old data
to find new insights,
or anything that's higher value
than sitting on their cluster,
they're not doing
because they're spending
their time on their cluster.
Leads to a whole bunch pain.
So scaling, even in
a cloud environment,
can be really tricky
and really painful.
Utilization-- unless you're
running ephemeral Spark
and Hadoop, utilization is
a bit of a moving target.
So you're trying
to plan out both
how much you think you need
right now-- which can actually
just be tricky-- and
how much you think
you might need in the future.
So unless you're using
ephemeral Spark and Hadoop,
you're trying to match
how much you're spending
with how much you're using.
And again, you're
performing more accounting
at that point and sort
of less engineering,
or less technology.
We really think that the cloud
should make just focusing
on your data much easier.
So instead of focusing
on the cluster itself,
we want you to focus
on the technology.
So you don't want to focus on
your Spark and Hadoop cluster.
You want to focus
on Spark and Hadoop.
And that's really why we went
out and design and continue
to invest in Cloud Dataproc.
So if you like
using Apache Spark,
and you think is often
new features in something
like Spark 2.3, which
there absolutely are,
we want you to focus on
those awesome new features
and the value they might
bring to your data,
not how you have to think about
when you can upgrade to Spark
2.3 on your cluster,
or how you're
going to try and fit it into
your existing production
workflows.
So with Cloud Dataproc,
and if anybody
has seen past presentations,
this is a familiar phrase.
And it's a familiar
phrase because it's
sort of our mission statement.
And it continues to underpin
our thinking and new features
that we develop
for Cloud Dataproc.
We want the Spark
and Hadoop ecosystem.
And when I say that, that's
the whole bucket of components.
There's a lot that
lives in there.
There's HBase and
Tez and Impala.
So I often abbreviate it, saying
Spark and Hadoop ecosystem.
But it's really that
whole big thing.
And some of it is,
well, most of it's
in the Apache
Software Foundation.
But a lot of it's also related.
It's privy things like Presto.
So just as a note,
when I say that,
I sort of mean I'm speaking
to the whole ecosystem.
And that's where Dataproc plays.
Fast, easy, and cost effective.
So realistically, we do want
you to spend less to do more.
Sales people love
me for saying this,
but when you're using
Spark and Hadoop,
save your money for
high value stuff.
If you have a Spark job, pay
us for the compute resources
and for the management
to go run that Spark job.
And then don't use the resources
when you don't have to.
Use them for something else.
Hire more people to look at
your data, or throw a party,
whatever.
We don't really care.
We just don't want you to
waste your time, your energy,
and your sanity.
When you look at sort of from
fully DIY to Cloud Dataproc,
there's a few differences.
Obviously, when we interact
with a lot of customers
at the beginning
of their journey,
they're running
their own managed
clusters, sometimes in a
cloud, sometimes on premise.
And they're taking
on the full burden.
So they're managing
their hardware.
They're managing the software.
They're managing
the configuration.
They may bring in a vendor to
help with the Hadoop stack,
which is the middle column.
So the vendor can help pre-tune
some of the components.
They will create
builds for them.
They'll often provide support.
But there's still a
lot that the customer
is responsible for managing.
With Cloud Dataproc,
we want to focus
on your code and your
data, and not other things.
That's not to say we want to
abstract away your ability
to do things like custom tune
Spark, or inject new libraries,
or do really advanced things.
Dataproc as a
Google Cloud Service
stands out because
it's really knobby.
You'll find a lot of
Google Cloud's services
are not knobby.
On purpose, Dataproc is
a very knobby service.
Our philosophy is we
want it to be knobby.
We want to preset those knobs
to the best of our ability.
And you'll see some
of the features
that we're working on
today to add new knobs
and preset those for you.
But we want you to be able
to override, to configure,
to tweak, but not have to think
about it if you don't want to.
Because most of
the time, you just
don't have to think about it.
Under the hood, Dataproc
has a few different layers.
I'm going to be describing
this left to right, just
so people can follow along.
Everything that
happens with Dataproc
generally happens
through the Dataproc API.
And that's not to say
that all interactions have
to happen through the
Cloud Dataproc API,
it's just how many
happen to work.
So all of our client
tooling, whether it's
the cloud console, or
the command line SDK,
they're all talking
Dataproc API.
There's endpoints for clusters,
jobs, operations, and now
very recently, workflows, where
you can specify a workflow that
will allow you to
create a cluster,
execute a graph of jobs,
and delete the cluster
in one operation.
That API will talk to Dataproc
clusters themselves, which are
built on top of Compute Engine.
Dataproc clusters have N
number of master nodes,
depending on whether
you're running
just standard
availability, which is one,
or high availability,
which is three.
Those nodes then run
Debian Jessie image,
with our open source
stack, which we use Apache
Bigtop to build on top of it.
You can install additional
components if you want to.
Likewise, since Dataproc is
running on Compute Engine,
you can do things like SSH
into the VMs if you so choose.
We also inherit all of the
power and functionalities
of Compute Engine, so
networks, GPUs, the ability
to create clusters without
public IPs attached to them,
all of that is inherently
part of Dataproc
because we're built
on Compute Engine.
You'll also see HDFS.
And HDFS is a bit of
an interesting odd duck
here because when you
created Dataproc cluster,
we do provision HDFS.
The goal is that you'd
only use that HDFS
for temporary operations, so
splitting, spilling, shuffling,
but you wouldn't store
data on HDFS persistently.
And the reason being is we
have a cloud storage connector
that's Hadoop compatible
file system compliant, which
allows you to use Cloud storage
as HDFS drop in replacement
without having to run your
cluster 24/7 just to run HDFS.
So when a lot people
moved to Cloud Dataproc,
the very first sort of
big savings for them
is just not running a
cluster all the time
to maintain their data.
Over the years there's been a
set of common pieces of advice
we've given customers
to try and help
them get onto Cloud Dataproc
as sort of painlessly
and effortlessly as possible.
First, separate
storage and compute.
And this goes to
my quip about HDFS.
So to the extent that you can
separate your data at rest
from your computation, you'll
save, obviously, effort.
You'll save money
because you won't
have to maintain the compute
needed just to store data.
It also allows you to do an
incremental move over time.
So if you separate out
your storage and compute,
you can do something like move
just a portion of your data
to a cloud.
You can experiment on it.
You can move maybe just a
few jobs to Cloud Dataproc,
see how it works,
iterate, rinse and repeat.
It means you don't have
to do a wholesale lift
and shift of your cluster
all at once, because that's
really difficult to do.
It means that people are trying
to move a lot of moving parts.
It's much easier to
do it incrementally.
When you also separate
out storage and compute,
it means that if you put
something, some storage
mechanism, like
Cloud storage, you
can use it without a Google
Cloud products, like BigQuery.
You don't have to
think about it.
Use of ephemeral and
long-lived clusters,
so Cloud Dataproc is
best used ephemerally,
because you can create
clusters in under 90 seconds.
You can delete
them at any point.
We bill by the second.
So from a performance
and economic standpoint,
there's a lot of reasons
to use ephemeral clusters.
You may not always be
able to, because you
have Spark Streaming, or
honestly, if you actually
just want to run a
persistent cluster,
some people prefer to do that
because the predictability
of their jobs is unknown.
They have internal SLAs
where seconds matter,
whatever the reason is.
Using a mix of ephemeral
and persistent clusters
works out for a lot of people.
Rightsizing clusters,
so open source packages
are great because they allow
you to do a whole lot of really
awesome things.
They're really hard to
use all on one cluster
because the way that
you need to configure
the environment, in
terms of the software,
in terms of the
compute resources,
maybe in terms of the location,
where your data is just
located, can all vary.
So depending on
the type of thing
that you want to do, maybe
the SLA that you'd have,
maybe you don't care
if your Java MapReduce
jobs take forever.
Maybe your biggest reason
for moving them to cloud
is to save money.
It's fine.
You can create a
small cluster, have it
finish whenever you're ready.
You can size it just to
fit your preferences.
If you have Spark and you want
it to run as fast as possible,
you can rightsize that
cluster for that use case.
Create and delete
clusters often--
the too long,
didn't read version
is if you don't have a
reason to keep your cluster,
just delete it.
Like, please don't give us
money to just run stuff and just
let it sit idle.
That's a bad use of your money.
The jobs API, so when we
meet a lot of customers
and they're moving
to Cloud Dataproc,
they're using things like
their own custom interfaces,
or web-based interfaces
to try and submit Hive QL,
or [INAUDIBLE]
managed Spark jobs.
Cloud Dataproc has a jobs API
that sits on top of clusters.
It allows you to
submit and monitor
jobs for some of the
more common job types.
We recommend that people do
it because you can do things
like stream output in real time.
The job metadata will
outlive the clusters.
So if you delete
the cluster, all
of the information about
your job will still be there.
It also just makes
your life easier.
You don't have to think about
web UIs to try and submit jobs.
You don't have to
think about trying
to create user
accounts for people
to be able to go create accounts
and submit jobs on clusters.
It just functionally makes
your life a lot easier.
The common advice has
worked out really well.
But there's a set
of new features
which are either in
Cloud Dataproc today
or are launching in the next
few weeks that will hopefully
make moving to Cloud Dataproc
just faster, and easier,
and more cost effective.
And Karthik's going
to run through some
of those new features with you.
He's going to run
through some of them,
but not necessarily all of them.
So if you are an avid
release note fan,
Cloud Dataproc does
do weekly releases.
As a teaser, there
are things that
are not covered
here that are also
coming out in the next few
weeks, just to set that up.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
Ready, so I'm Karthik.
I am a software engineer
on the Cloud Dataproc team.
And I'm going to introduce
you to three new features.
So the first place,
custom images,
so our base Dataproc images
come with four components,
Hadoop, Spark, Hive, and Pig.
But oftentimes you want
to run more than that.
Sometimes you can bring
your Java dependencies
with your job.
But oftentimes you need
to bring a lot more.
So if you installing
servers, or you're
compiling Python
dependencies from source,
that can take a lot longer.
So once your
initialization actions
take more than
just a few minutes,
now if you create
a large cluster,
either your [INAUDIBLE]
actions, I've
even heard a customer
take an hour.
Now you're spending
all that time
just configuring
the cluster, not
actually processing the data.
So the custom image,
you can build an image
and then give that to Dataproc
to use for your clusters.
And that really helps you
use ephemeral clusters.
So I'm going to just
go through a quick demo
here of creating a custom image.
So first, actually, I have
this [? basch ?] script
called Install Kitchen Sink.
So I'm installing Jupyter,
RStudio, Apache Zeppelin,
TensorFlow, and the HBase
client for Bigtable.
So just a bunch of
random things that
take several minutes to do as
[INAUDIBLE] action normally.
So since I don't want
to waste your time,
this would take a few minutes.
But I already have a
custom image pre-built.
So I'm going to create
a cluster based on that.
All right.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, so as you can
see, the default here
is the base Dataproc image.
And I'm going to go ahead and
change that to a custom image
here.
[? Hit ?] demo project, and this
is the one I already pre-built.
So I'm gonna select that,
go ahead and create it.
All right, so 452, anyone
want to guess how long this
will take to create?
60 seconds, a little bit
longer than 60 seconds.
I'd guess closer to 90 seconds.
But as this is
creating here, you
can see that there's
a custom image.
I can go ahead and click on it.
And this image is in
the GCE images list.
And so this is managed by me.
And so I can go ahead and delete
it if I don't want it anymore.
All right, then click that one.
All right, I'm going to
quickly show you here.
Just kidding, the cluster
is not created yet.
But I just was gonna show
you, yes, now it is created.
Oh, hello.
There we go.
So check here,
Kitchen Sink Demo 2.
There you go.
All right, so you can see
that this cluster already
has Jupyter pre-installed
because it created a cluster
with this custom image.
And I have this like
TensorFlow Hello World
here that we could run.
So that's custom images.
All right, so the second feature
I want to talk about here
is Dataproc workflows.
So with the workflows,
you can specify a cluster
that you want jobs
to run on, and also
the jobs that you want to run.
So this really gets to kind
of using ephemeral clusters.
Previously, you
would need to manage
three different operations.
You need to create a cluster,
run jobs, and then delete
a cluster.
Well, with workflows you can
do all of that in one step,
so really helping with
the automation there.
All right, I just kind
of went deep dive here.
With the workflow cluster, you
can either specify a cluster
that the workflow will
create just for those jobs
and tear down at the end, or
you can give it a selector.
So if you want to manage
your own pool of clusters,
let's say you have several
clusters with the same label,
then you can ask
the workflow API
to run jobs on the least
loaded cluster with that label.
So I'll quickly show you here.
So this is a workflow template.
I like to use YAML files
to specify my workflows.
So this is a pretty
common Hadoop work
[? legis ?] called TeraSort.
So I have TeraGen to
generate a terabyte of data,
TeraSort sorts
the data, and then
TeraValidate validates that
it was sorted correctly.
And you can see that I'm using
[? pats ?] on Google Cloud
Storage here for the data.
And then finally at the bottom
of this file, in this case,
I have a managed cluster.
And the only configuration
I was setting
was the number of workers.
So two is probably not enough
workers for this cluster.
So I'm going to go ahead and set
it to 100, as just as a guess.
So I can go ahead
and create this.
So instantiate from file.
Cool, so this workflow is
going to create a cluster,
run the three jobs one-by-one,
and then finally delete
the cluster at the end.
So I don't need to manage
those steps independently.
So as you can see here,
it's creating a cluster.
All right, and again,
canceling is also simple.
So if I don't want to actually
wait for this to finish,
can go ahead and cancel it.
So pretty neat, helped me get
rid of a lot of [? basch ?]
scripts, actually.
All right, so this is the last
feature I wanted to talk about,
autoscaling.
So as James was talking
about before, one
of the real benefits of Cloud
infrastructure is that you can
provision and delete nodes,
delete VMs on demand.
But before with
Dataproc, you would still
have to notice that your cluster
was either underutilized,
or maybe you had a lot
of work queuing up.
And so you'd have to
manually resize the cluster.
But now we have autoscaling.
So as James was
mentioning, we do
try to be a more knobby
feature than a lot
of the rest of Google Cloud.
So with autoscaling, you
have complete control.
A lot of these do
have defaults, but you
can specify things like
the min and max workers
for primary, substandard,
and preemptable workers.
You can specify the cooldown
period, so how often
the autoscale decides to scale.
There are things like graceful
de-commissioning and several
other properties.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is scale
down [INAUDIBLE]??
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: It can.
So yeah, the question
was can it scale down?
And the answer is yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
Say that again?
AUDIENCE: Physical [INAUDIBLE].
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
Yes, so I'll explain.
So a quick like
little deep dive here.
The way this works, it is
purely based on Hadoop Yarn.
So if unfamiliar, Yarn is
the scheduler of Hadoop.
So if I have 100 nodes
and each has 10 gigabytes,
then I have 1,000 gigabytes
of virtual Yarn memory
in my cluster.
So if I have available memory
from Yarn's perspective,
that means that I'm
actually overprovisioned.
I have too many nodes.
And I can scale down.
And similarly, if there's
a lot of work queued up
in Yarn that doesn't have
space to be allocated,
I have pending memory.
And that means I need
to scale up the cluster.
So the autoscaling policy
is purely based on that.
And so when we're talking
about Spark, Spark as a job,
as executors exit, then you'll
end up having available memory.
And so we'll remove VMs
to match that workload.
So a quick demo here, I actually
love using workflow templates.
So I just modified my
previous workflow template
and added some
autoscaling properties.
So here I have a max of 100
standard workers and 100
preemptable workers, so a total
of a maximum of 200 nodes.
And I asked it to
scale every 10 minutes.
All right, and just
for fun, I decided
to add in the custom
image we built earlier.
So similarly here would
be instantiate from file.
And of course, this would
take several minutes
to run, actually more
like an hour to run.
So we're not going to
wait here for that.
I have run this before.
And I'll show you the dashboard.
So this is Stackdriver.
All right, so there
were three jobs.
You can kind of see
them on the left here.
The green right here
is pending memory.
So this is work queued up.
And you can really
think this as the amount
of work remaining in the job.
So this first stage
here is TeraGen.
So you can see
this is definitely
smaller than TeraSort.
So what happens here
is that initially it's
very slow to progress.
You can see that it's
pretty flat on the left.
But then if you look
over here, the autoscaler
scales up, which makes the
work go down a lot faster.
Similarly, TeraSort
is a lot bigger job.
So there's a lot
more pending memory,
and again the
autoscaler scales up.
And so again, the
slope is a lot steeper
as the work finishes faster.
And then finally,
TeraValidate, the cluster
is about the right size.
And so it's mostly constant.
And then finally it's deleted.
So, pretty neat.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
[INAUDIBLE] at the very end,
I was wondering that too.
You can see that it kind
of goes up here as well.
Pending memory is
still non-zero.
So there is still
actually work pending.
At the very end,
the cluster just
gets deleted before the
next cool down period.
And so that's why it
just drops off there.
I have one more
kind of neat demo.
So this one was not done from
a workflow template, which
is actually why there's like a
few hours where the cluster was
just sitting idle.
I actually forgot to delete it.
So use workflow templates.
OK, so this workload, I was
adding more and more load up
to kind of this
point here, and then
reduced the load throughout.
So the chart, sorry about that.
So this is actually
a bit misleading.
I am still increasing the
workload as it falls down.
It's just that the
autoscaler scaled up
as it detected
more and more work.
So around here, the cluster
is about the right size.
And then when I add
a ton more work,
again, the cluster scales up.
And then finally as
the work comes down,
it scales back down.
So that's autoscaling.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Autoscaling
[INAUDIBLE]..
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
So the question
was, does autoscaling
only work with workflows?
The answer is no.
It's based on Dataproc
cluster properties.
So in G Cloud, if you ever use
[? dash dash ?] properties,
you know often for
Spark properties,
it's the same thing.
And we will have more
time for Q&A at the end.
So don't worry too much.
So a quick recap, I'll go
back to presenting here.
So we created a custom image.
We wrote workflow templates.
We enabled autoscaling.
And we saw the
cluster autoscale.
So again, this
really gets to kind
of us becoming a more
and more managed service,
really helping you
automate your workflows.
So with that, I'll
hand it back to James.
JAMES MALONE: So a few of those
features are there right now.
Autoscaling's coming
in the next few weeks.
The feature that I
alluded to earlier
is also coming in a few weeks,
is selectable components,
where you can pick and choose
what you want installed
on your cluster, which should
make it easier to customize
the cluster to your liking.
If you are curious and
want to get started more
with Cloud Dataproc,
there is a few things
that you can check out.
There is a set of
migration guides, which
we're expanding over time.
Migration guides are written
from the perspective of,
you already have a monolithic,
or several monolithic Spark
and Hadoop clusters.
You want to move
them to Google Cloud.
There is information in
the migration guides,
right now about moving your
jobs, and moving your data.
We're expanding that
soon with a guide
on how to think about a
security model in a cloud
environment versus a traditional
on-premise environment.
The Cloud Dataproc docs always
have our newest features.
So when we release new features,
we release documentation.
If you are really curious
to stay up-to-date
with Dataproc features,
the best thing to do
is actually just follow the
RSS feed for our release notes.
We do a weekly release
behind the scenes.
If you ever look at the
Cloud Dataproc images,
you'll see that they're
incremented every week.
And the reason is
is we're continually
building new images every week.
So it's a really good
way to stay up-to-date.
We also have a
Stack Overflow tag.
The team actually looks
at new questions that
come to the Stack Overflow tag.
If you have a question
you think others might
be interested in that
question, or you think
there might already
be an answer,
I strongly encourage you to use
that tag, both just as a basis
to see if somebody already
has asked a question,
or just to share your question
so others might be able to find
that information as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]